una pequeña ciudad destruida por la
guerra como muchas otras del sur de
Ucrania pero maest fue tomada brevemente
por los rusos antes de quedar en el
frente durante varios meses
este pueblo solía tener seis mil
habitantes Ahora solo hay unos cientos
tengo 90 años
es la Segunda Guerra que atravieso Pero
esta vez me hirieron
cada tres semanas aproximadamente una de
las clínicas móviles de médicos Sin
fronteras que operan en la región se
desplaza a esta aldea el número de
pacientes aumenta constantemente hoy
hemos venido a hacer una clínica móvil
tenemos dos médicos dos médicos
generales un psicólogo y una enfermera
[Música]
proporcionamos medicinas y consultas
gratuitas a la población del pueblo
el equipo de msf trabaja en conjunto con
el personal sanitario ucraniano que
atiende todo tipo de patologías crónicas
[Música]
en medio de una población angustiada por
el regreso de los rusos los dolores del
cuerpo se juntan con el malestar de la
Salud Mental
[Música]
a menudo nos enfrentamos a la depresión
la ansiedad
el miedo a volver a ver los combates
el estrés postraumático
los equipos de médicos Sin fronteras han
recorrido buena parte de la región de
jerson cuatro meses después de la salida
del ejército Ruso y la exploración en
los pueblos está lejos de haber
terminado
vamos a un pueblo en el que nunca hemos
estado para hacer una evaluación
no estamos muy seguros de la demografía
nos han dicho que hay unas 100 personas
explorar las zonas liberadas no está
exento de peligros
los bordes de las carreteras siguen
siendo muy peligrosos sigue habiendo
Minas dentro de los pueblos
llegamos a tabrisky aquí esperamos
rehabilitar la clínica del pueblo pero
la tarea parece muy complicada Olga una
voluntaria del pueblo muestra lo que
queda de la clínica
no creo que haya nada que hacer aquí
para rehabilitar
creo que está muerto llevaría demasiado
tiempo y mucha inversión
es repugnante este es un centro de salud
que fue alcanzado por un cohete es un
impacto directo no es un impacto lateral
es directo
será necesario recurrir a un edificio
del pueblo que pueda albergar la clínica
móvil Aquí hay una escuela
y cuando vinieron nuestros soldados
repararon el techo y arreglaron las
ventanas pero no hay calefacción
a pocos minutos a la entrada del pueblo
hay una escuela que no acoge a niños
desde hace mucho tiempo
el edificio ha sufrido pero no le
vendrían mal algunas obras
ahora la gente está volviendo estamos
Unidos y nos ayudamos mutuamente Estamos
contentos no estamos tristes qué quieres
que hagamos cuando lloramos finalmente
la jornada fue un éxito Con mucho
trabajo una clínica móvil podrá venir e
instalarse regularmente en esta escuela
por supuesto No atenderá casos graves
que irán a los hospitales de la región
pero aliviará a una población que lleva
casi un año Privada de la atención
sanitaria